and yesterday the president tweeted
quote the liberal left also known as the
Democrats want to get rid of ice who do
a fantastic job and want open borders
crime would be rampant and
uncontrollable make America great again
joining me now to discuss as
concentrated president
Kellyanne Conway all right good evening
Kellyanne I have to tell you something I
just wrote it down again when they say
ice isn't doing what it was created to
do what do they think ice was created to
do serve coffee and date well that's an
excellent question that nobody is asking
them I think it's time to tamp down the
emotion go for some of the information
if you quizzed most of those people
including elected officials as to why
ice was created in the first place in
response to 9/11 and what it is supposed
to be doing and by the way what it does
do at the White House we're working on
that exact document so that people get
information ice provides so many
services that are critical to everyone's
security in this country Janine do you
know and Kirsten Gillibrand is jumping
on the abolished eyestrain up in New
York where she's a United States Senator
the ice has removed 40 criminal aliens
in in recent weeks I mean she's she's
gone against the security of her own
people when she calls for this nonsense
Cynthia Nixon and after who happens to
be running for governor against Andrew
Cuomo and pulling him to the left is
saying there are terrorist organization
that you've got it backwards they stop
terrorists from coming into the country
they also seized thousands of pounds of
narcotics and they get rid of child
smugglers and they detect people who are
transnational gang members I mean the
president is putting it this way it's a
binary choice you're there for open
borders and the crime that comes with
that or you're for a sovereign nation
that has physical borders and and less
crime and let me say one more thing you
see this argument now with the Democrats
you've got some of the older more senior
Democrats saying well I don't think
abolishing Isis is a good idea and you
got Democrats disingenuously talking
about immigration reform when President
Trump brought them to the table in the
Cabinet Room for one solid hour in
January all they wanted to talk
was the dreamers was daca they didn't
want to talk about immigration reform
the president's the one with a 70 point
immigration plan that he boiled down to
four points it's been up for a vote in
Congress they're being disingenuous and
that when they say they want to do this
well clearly I mean the president was
willing to go with daca and they weren't
I mean think about it when Obama was
president and he had the ability in the
house in the Senate he didn't do
anything and you know they want to make
it an issue or so it seems and never
resolve it so they can they can say
that's Republicans are against it but
what I don't understand Kellyanne it's
like saying to people we don't want this
police force and immigrants should be
able to come in we don't want to know
who they are what their records are if
they have a record we just you know
don't care anymore do people not
understand the in pain oh actually
finances here that's right well I think
the average American does I think
Americans do understand the impact on
their financial security on their their
everyday security but also you see this
mark pat mark Penn was Hillary Clinton's
pollster and chief strategist he came
out with a Harvard Harris poll where he
asked a question about abolishing ice do
you know not abolishing ice keeping ice
as it is got try partisan support
majorities of Republicans Democrats and
independents all agreed that abolishing
ice is not a good idea so these
Democrats who are just trying to out
left each other for 2020 having done
absolutely nothing in 2017 or 2018 that
I can point to they're already thinking
about 2020 folks do something in 2018
that's meaningful so they're going
they're saying abolish ice but basically
they're you know they're instead of
advising consent they're doing obstruct
and distract instead of abolish ice they
should be thinking about how to protect
our borders and there are a lot of
Democrats I think getting very nervous
about where the party is truly going and
and and let's see who's following them
leftward off the cliff well I think that
you know when the president said in that
that recent interview he said you know
what it's a great issue if they want to
go forward with that then you and I both
know the president has great instincts
he really gets it
he's an outsider president he made it
everyone said he wouldn't make it I mean
he gets it that Americans the in
addition to a cotton the economy they
want safety and security and by saying
we want open borders run abolish ice we
want something who said they wanted
something kinder and they don't want a
deportation force and let's reimagine
ice whatever that means
hey Janine guess what they say they're
from open borders but none of them has
the guts to go and put the bill they go
out to the protest they don't go in the
well the Senate they don't go in the
house and introduce rules that say we're
going to reimagine borders we're going
to reimagine the fact that Congress made
it a crime to enter the country
illegally none of them have the guts to
do that where's the piece of legislation
it's cheap and easy to go wave a sign
and go scream into a megaphone it's
harder work to come back here to
Washington and actually do your jobs and
you know what this president he's on
task every single day and he ran
successfully on issues like illegal
immigration like having borders and
security and he always talks about the
drugs that are pouring in also he's on
top of that as well well she's a lot of
people President huge issue you know
President Obama this past weekend that's
why your President Obama this past
weekend told the Democrats you got to do
more than mope they've gone from hope to
mope and they're wondering where he is
why he's not a stronger voice why isn't
he speaking up and speaking out on the
number of these issues other than
$400,000 speeches so they're just
arrested we're not paying attention to
that we're just going to get borders
sovereign nation with borders all right
I want to ask you about Supreme Court
nominees I'm curious to women in the
group the group is a very small group
maybe five maybe seven what do you think
well don't forget the list is 25 and
that's really the key here this
president has been transferred the
president down to five year maybe two
we've got Amy Barrett and Joan Larson
what do you think of them well I'm not
going to comment or so I can tell you
that every one that the president is
considered checks all the boxes for
brilliant and capable a judicial
temperament not putting
their own personal feelings where the
Constitution belongs the law the
judiciary interprets the laws it does
not make the laws we got too many judges
today making things up as they go along
the executive executes them the
legislative branch should be making them
but it's the it's the interpretive
function of the judiciary that's so
important here this president said he
wants academic and professional
credentials and I think anyone you see
on the list are people of great
intellect and great experience honorable
men and women on the President's List
and look the president put out his list
and then he added to the list Janine
this man is so transparent and
accountable in such an important
decision I want to tell you somebody who
spent some time with him today as well
on this issue I just have to tell you he
understands the gravity as he has said
nominating to the Supreme Court is one
of the most important things that any
president does every prayer every all
the nominees all the justice on the
Supreme Court out out last anyone's
presidency of eight years but in many
ways some of these tourists out outlast
the presidents who actually nominated
they understand he understands that
you're talking about 30 40 45 years of
jurisprudence and he takes the decision
very with with great gravity and
responsibility now other people are
advising but it is his decision to make
and he's been very respectful to 98
senators on the right and the left you
know who are advising and consenting as
well well I have a feeling that the
president will probably as with Gorsuch
get the person on the Supreme Court that
he wants anyway Kellyanne Conroy so good
to have you on the show tonight thank
you